there's a recent report that indicates
that 71% of anti-semitic incidents in
the United States last year were
committed by right-wingers which I don't
think comes a surprise comes as a
surprise to most people and this came up
during my debate about free speech with
Tim Poole on our YouTube channel earlier
this week which by the way is now
archived on YouTube I encourage you to
watch it there's some interesting stuff
in there and it's important to
understand that not all anti-semitism is
on the right but according to
anti-defamation league data about 71% of
anti-semitic incidents last year were
committed by right-wingers also not
surprisingly there's a new report out
which exposes that there are neo-nazi
networks within the United States
military this also is not going to be a
surprise to many people independent
media outlet unicorn riot published an
investigation which found that there are
11 specific members of a group called
identity Europa Europa with a with a V
instead of a U as the second letter
which is a neo-nazi organization its
operating in the US military and there
are specific members that they know of
who are currently in the United States
military unicorn riot and HuffPost found
that plenty of people who spend their
free time posting anti-semitic memes and
praising Adolf Hitler on the Internet
currently our members of the United
States military now the investigations
actually names some names and some of
the individuals are relatively high
ranking ranking including a lieutenant
colonel who's a doctor in the Army
Reserves as one example and a few months
ago at the end of 2018 ProPublica did
their own investigation and exposed that
there's another neo-nazi Network with
members in the military it's a group
called the Adam Waffen division which
focused on or focuses on recruiting on
college campuses and distributing fliers
and members of the Adam Waffen division
have been implicated in five murders in
the last two years now some of their
members have been tied to plots to bomb
synagogues and nuclear power plants and
they have active members who
currently in the United States military
and none of this really is news right
there was a poll from the military times
a few years ago where 25% of military
members said they encountered white
nationalism in the ranks and that number
is probably higher but I would
understand that there are probably some
people in the military that don't want
to admit that they've encountered white
nationalism in the military so it might
seem sort of obvious that an
organization that lets you carry guns it
might let you go to war maybe you'd get
to kill people that that would attract
violent fascist elements of society so
in a sense it is obvious but it's not
just the military that's at issue it's
really a cultural issue and what I mean
by that is if you look at other
countries yes the military is a job
where you carry guns and maybe you get
to kill people and that's more likely to
appeal to violent fascist elements but
the culture surrounding war and
masculinity and all of these other
issues works as a sort of exacerbating
factor in the United States where you
have a huge contingent that supports
aggressive foreign policy you've got the
problem of our relationship to guns you
have lack of access to mental health
that you have right now a president
whose rhetoric has inflamed this type of
violent ideology so of course you end up
with a military that contains these
extreme elements and my point is even if
the military in some general way is more
likely to attract people predisposed to
violence or to wanting to have the
opportunity to maybe kill people or
shoot people it doesn't actually have to
be as bad as it is in the United States
the military does provide opportunities
to people who might be lacking
opportunities but it also provides
opportunities to people with the
masculinity complex to people who have
these extreme beliefs in their countries
supremacy or their races supremacy and
to the military's credit in the u.s.
they do have formal prohibitions against
service members participating in these
groups of course they don't they don't
catch everybody and that's really the
issue we have enough problems with the
engagements that our presidents choose
to involve our military and
we don't also need to aggravate that
with extremist fascists inside of the
service and the results of this study
are very very concerning